oh  bye  oh  no  oh  no no no  oh  [Music]  god  oh  boy oh dad i don't want to stop your  flow but can you pass the peel off oh  god that's butter you know what butter's  better  [Music]  you have seven days to make your payment  seven it's gonna be okay bob  happy  hopeful  kissy lips  please  oh  my god louise don't go down there it's  dangerous  did you mean to wave your arms all over  the place while falling into the hole  because if so you nailed it yes it all  went great  sister please  i'd like to report on  a thing happened  what do we do ideas go oh oh what's this  thing  i'm so nervous  i know can you believe it  [Music]  this is getting oh  son of a butt  hmm that feels nice i know i know don't  rub my sesame seeds off i won't don't  worry they're a cute couple uh i give  them a year  [Music]  you